So I think Charlie was
a great interviewee.
I think she did excellent job
at answering my questions.
She definitely took her time thinking,
right, she thought, she didn't feel
rushed trying to answer my questions.
And that's very important because it
allowed me to stay connected with her.
I think she did an excellent job with
answering the questions in general,
she went straight to the answers
which was very good.
I think she was very good at
explaining what she was thinking and
taking me with her through
the process of getting to the answer,
which i think is very important.
There are three things
that she did very well and
the first one was guiding me
through her thought process.
Whenever I asked her a question
she would not just rush in and
start answering.
I asked her a SQL question, right,
and she explained exactly what
she was going to write before she
even started writing on the board.
Same with a programming question,
she told me how she would solve it.
She told me how it's not
the optimal solution.
We agreed that it was
a good enough solution.
She started writing.
I think that those are that
the most important thing
to do in a technical interview.
And she was very clear with how she
explained which is something that they
don't is you need to be very good at I
would look for I want her to be able to
explain things to other people
because it's a huge part of our job.
The things that she could have worked
on a little bit more was definitely
being more familiar with the machine,
learning algorithm that she
mentioned during the interview.
I think another point where she might
be able to improve a little bit,
is when once she saw
the program in question.
When she went to work through examples.
It was a bit too fast it was
kind of hard for me to follow.
So maybe even making a table of
what a viable look like operation
to ration of the for loop.
Might help me be able to keep keep
up with what she was saying and
stay connected with her.
And you know I think she
did a good interview.